here it is
as acting chair of the
children and family law committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor as a result of
the covet 19 pandemic and in accordance
with house rule 67 and the governor's
emergency order number 12 pursuant to
executive order 2020-04
this public body is authorized to meet
electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee and scheduled
in the house calendar for today
an executive session may be held on any
bill referred to the committee at any
posted time
please note that there is no physical
location for members of the public to
observe and listen
contemporaneously to this meeting
however in accordance with the emergency
order i am confirming that
all members of the committee and select
legislative staff have the ability to
communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting through the zoom
electronic meeting platform
and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen and if
necessary participate in this meeting by
zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar and through the electronic
calendar on the general court website
the notice for this meeting complies
with house rules rsa 91a
and anyone who has a problem accessing
the meeting should call
603-271-3600
or
email
c s at leg dot state dot nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access the meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and or rescheduled
please note that all votes that are
taken during this meeting shall be done
by roll call
we start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state whether there is
anyone in the room with you
during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law
does everybody understand what i just
read
yes
i'm sorry that was so perfect but i
missed all of it you're gonna have to
repeat it
okay no
thank you all
uh
madam clerk would you please call the
role
certainly
children and family law committee
attendance
representative paul schiller
representative belanger
i am present in the lob with madam chair
and representative john lewicki
representative cross
vice chair representative desimone
good morning i am here in the lob rooms
210 to 11.
i have my mask in case i get closer but
i am 10 feet away from representative
belanger and representative
lewicki thank you
representative grossman
she's connecting to audio hold on
good morning everyone
good morning representative grossman
we're taking attendance i just called
your name
i am in my house in exeter alone
two days in a row
representative levite
i am in my spare
your room alone
thank you
representative wiki
i'm at the lob
in the meeting room
representative litchfield
representative long
i'm in my home and i'm alone
representative petryno
good morning i'm home in my home office
alone
thank you
madam vice chair will representative
stephen smith be joining us for
chair right
as far as i know uh brad representative
brad greenland
will be joining us
just
being
the host for the meeting i am just a
staff member
okay thank you mr greenland um i do not
know who will be subbing
for representative
rice today
i will check with staff
and get back to you
okay thank you
representative denise smith
president i am alone in my living room
but um
i have children sorry my phone's ringing
um my children are home and that was my
husband
thank you
representative
wizzy wazzier
good morning
i am home with three of my own children
and my little brother
thank you
representative yo keller
yes i'm home alone
thank you
uh
the clerk representative ali sayyah i
have contractors
working coming in and out and a puppy
thank you
thank you and good morning everyone
thank you for coming this morning um
this morning we're going to be trying to
stay on task and i will uh
i am turning
the um
electronics over to representative cody
uh cody belanger
and he will be the one to be answering
hands and turning things over to
all of who choose to speak on the
various bills
representative ultra chiller just text
me that she cannot find her unique link
so if staff could send
representative all chiller her unique
link
i will send it over to her now
who was that
that spoke
it was a uh brad greenland from house
community services
thank you brad madam chair
melissa litchfield says she can't get on
brad can you send her one as well
can you send it to
thank you
we're going to give it a few seconds for
both of those people to be able to
access the meeting if that's okay
with everybody else
i don't want anybody to miss anything
because they can't
get into the meeting so if there is
anybody out there who is a legislator on
this committee and you cannot get in
please
text
either representative long
or myself and we will have
the staff send you the link thank you
madam chair
yes representative
i noticed that representative
altschiller has arrived
yes
she just stepped away
um
if someone arrives if they can
[Music]
let me know and let me know if
if they're alone or whom they're with
may i have permission to call her name
for attendance at this time
yes ma'am please do and also please um
i think we had somebody else signing in
to uh representative yokela is now here
representative litchfield is now here if
you could call their names
and they can answer your questions thank
you
okay
representative halstealer
good morning i am here in stratham alone
thank you
representative litchfield
hi good morning um i am in my home right
now um
i have my son and my husband here as
well they are in different rooms but
they are in the home as well
and i do have representative yokela
thank you
thank you madam clerk
i think we're all set now to begin
thank you all again for coming and the
first on the agenda was house bill 494
i will open the bill
and then
we can
check out who's
wanting to testify and so forth
thank you again and good morning
i am representative deborah desimone i
represent rockingham county district 14
and i'm going to introduce my bill this
bill provides that the court shall not
issue an order in a divorce proceeding
that infringes on a party's
constitutional rights
unless the court determines there is no
less restrictive means to achieve a
compelling
government interest
one of the reasons that this bill has
been brought forward
is uh because there uh
is a need
relative to the temporary relief and
permanent restraining orders issued in a
divorce proceeding
and we want to make it a more fair
field of play as it were and i'm not
taking it
lightly it is a very serious situation
so with that i will ask
representative
belanger to allow
mr j markell
who assisted me in writing this
to speak on this subject
thank you
is my mute
my button working here can you hear me
we can hear you mr markell
thank you madam chairman uh the basis
for this bill is is that it's to remedy
what uh
we view here
as a couple of stat key statutory
problems that exist in the divorce
statute and the companion bill which is
4.95 it might be
there because the remedy is the same and
the defect in the statute is the same
let me explain
uh if you look at rsa 458 16 section one
what we do is we have we have a grant of
authority which disregards the federal
and state constitution it allows
a family court judge to disregard the
federal and state constitutions the way
it's being interpreted let me explain
and give you a concise overview it says
uh
45816 says after the filing of a
petition for divorce annulment or
separation or decree of nullity the
superior court now obviously that's
family court today okay may issue orders
with such conditions and limitations as
the court deems just and may at the
discretion of the court be made on a
temporary or permanent basis uh then it
goes on
uh we have the same basically the same
tracking language in rsa 468 461 a10
the problem here is is that and this is
a solution for an existing problem is is
that it conveys
many courts are reading this as a uh
basically a license to do whatever they
want to do without regard to uh constant
without regard to the limits on the
constitution that are placed
um
by the way what this bill does is is
that it deals with a compelling
government interest let me explain
um
the ability to issue equitable orders
does actually come up against the
federal and state constitutions
people do not surrender all of their
constitutional rights merely because
they there is a petition for divorce or
a parenting petition filed now
let's be clear
this exempts
domestic violence petitions
because there's a compelling government
interest in protecting victims of
domestic violence there is uh and
protecting children and this also does
not apply to abuse or neglect petitions
this does not apply to anything else
like that it also does not apply
necessarily to parenting orders and the
reason why is because this bill says
that it applies to enumerated rights
under the federal and state
constitutions so it is a strict
limitation
uh you have a you have constitutional
rights to parent which are found which
arise within the constitution but they
are not enumerated rights and you
impliedly waive that when you file
basically a parenting petition or a
petition for divorce particularly where
there are children involved because then
the state can assert a compelling
interest in seeing that children are
protected the state can also uh assert a
compelling government interest in seeing
that parties are protected so what
importantly what this doesn't do
it
lets courts issue orders that protect
people okay it does not it does not
disturb that at all
uh you know anti-harassment orders are
still in place domestic violence orders
are still in place courts have broad
general discretion to do anything they
to do anything within reason that will
be a sustainable exercise of discretion
by the way it's worthy of note when you
look at restraining orders particularly
under rsa 468
458-16 when we're talking about um
entering premises and things like that
uh staying away from people's work which
is the same thing under rsa 468 a10
what is not
what is not a restriction within the
statute
is entering some is entering a house of
worship so in other words the statutes
actually do impliedly recognize the
first amendment which is that you have a
right of freedom of worship
so what we're merely saying with this
is that the court is still free to craft
individual remedies that address the
needs of a case
what it just says is
is is that if you intend to infringe on
a constitutional right which is already
identified within the constitution all
we're saying is
your honor
please identify the right that is being
infringed
uh
tell us why this is necessary to achieve
a compelling government interest
and tell us why
there is no less restrictive way of
achieving this compelling government
interest and just make written findings
that's all you really have to do
um it's no burden on the court it
clarifies things it also puts parties on
notice as to uh
what what people can do and what they
can't do there seems to be a widely held
misconception
that somehow
there is a family law exception to the
federal and state constitutions
there is not
okay
while the constitution does not come
into play as often as it does in say
criminal cases
nevertheless
we do have these rights
uh once again
this is not a domestic violence statute
all it does this is not this does not
infringe on the rights of victims it
still protects victims it just says to
the court let's apply the law and that
there are constitutional limitations so
you can view this as curative
what it does is that it really just
clarifies
what the court's discretion is and that
court's discretions have limitations um
now one of the things i did earlier this
morning was i
emailed the committee not only a copy of
the two statutes so it can read it but i
emailed a copy of the shack decision
which came out of
the massachusetts supreme judicial court
which deals with the first amendment
and it talks about prior restraint and
it gives a good overview of how
important rights are um and this is in
the family law context so for example
um
can you just so for example in our
parenting plans we say
you can't if you're a parent disparage
another parent in front of that child
and that's gonna stand and the reason
why it's good law is because the state
has a compelling government interest in
seeing children not being emotionally
damaged by a by a parent uh denigrating
another parent in the child's presence
that's going to stand up that's fine
these are just some examples now from
the real world let's look at whether or
not this is simply a solution looking
for a problem
well i can tell you that i'm just one
person and over the last 18 months
i have
i have received orders outside of the
restraining order context because note
that this statute not only applies to
restraining orders but all orders the
reason it's in the harassment statute is
in the restraining order statute is
because that's where you may find a lot
of violations to occur but please note
that it applies to all orders so for
example when you have two bickering
parents
and they don't seem to be able to arrive
at anything should a court order prior
restraint by saying something like the
parties
for example
may not discuss
prior issues
may not be must be non-sarcastic
civil and forward-looking in their
discussions now
that became an order of the court
outside of a restraining order now
that is what's called prior restraint
which
gets very strict scrutiny under the
federal and state constitutions and
under irrelevant u.s supreme court law
and that's why i've got the shaq
decision down there for you so you can
read it and get kind of a better handle
on how courts view this uh the new
hampshire supreme court also deals in
prior restraint which is basically a
form of censorship
okay
we come down in this society as against
censorship in most all circumstances
interestingly enough while many of the
violations
would probably be of the first amendment
type freedom of speech things like that
nevertheless
i had one which actually violated the
eighth amendment to the federal
constitution and um
article 18
of the new hampshire constitution
in a situation where
a man was taxed
alimony and child support in excess of
100 of his income
now um
the background on this
is that um
the man agreed committed domestic
violence and he went to jail
okay no question he did wrong but the
court in an independent order
okay for alimony after first finding out
he had no ability to pay alimony
nevertheless decided to change its
course and direction
and actually taxed him alimony to a
hundred percent of his income and i
think you would find in the orders it
was a strong consideration that he had
committed some domestic violence when we
pointed out to the court that this was a
violation of the eighth amendment which
was at that time in 2019
made applicable to the states for
excessive fines
and by the way which already existed in
new hampshire under the excessive fine
statute under the excessive fines
constitution under the new hampshire
amendment they actually re they actually
backed the court actually backed away
from the order
now
i have another case
where in the restraining order context
uh
a court issues an order that says the
parties may only communicate
through parenting applications through a
parenting application such as talking
parents now that is fine because that's
a legitimate time place and manner
restriction
okay and courts can do that with no
problem and they don't get strict
scrutiny but
the court said they may only discuss
parenting issues
now
the client in this particular case had a
very good lawsuit against the other
party because of destruction of property
and a few other things
under that under that court order he
can't even settle a case without being
settled for contempt
and by the way contempts in the state of
new hampshire you know do a couple of
things number one is is that they stain
a person's court reputation
number two
uh they may trigger attorney's fees
number three in extreme cases you can be
sent to jail now
carry this one step further
supposing somebody and by the way please
be aware
the power to contempt
and order to jail is within the
discretion of the court
so can you imagine engaging in otherwise
first amendment and new hampshire
protected speech
one minute please
okay non-threatening non-harassing
and can you imagine being sent to jail
on something like that so what this does
is this cures the existing defect that
exists in the two statutes um and all it
says is judge
if you're going to infringe on a
constitutional right which you might be
able to do
tell us why you have to do it tell us
why there is no other less restrictive
way of doing it and please identify the
right that you're going to infringe on
that's really kind of it in a nutshell
thank you mr markell any questions from
mr markell
representative long you can unmute
yourself
thank you madam chair uh thank you
attorney markell
i don't deal with this every day so
um i get lost a lot of times when you
testify and keep adding cases i
but i pick up what i can uh so looking
at this bill so the court is responsible
for identifying
a right infringed correct correct so if
the court deems that the right
isn't infringing any state or federal
constitution
but a
party
to the proceedings do how would that
work
okay uh well
when you say how would that work can you
try to i'm trying to answer your
question well i disagree with the judge
but it doesn't give me the opportunity
to say
that my rights being in french that's up
to the judge to identify
my rights being the french well no you
have a right to make you you know you
with all due respect representative long
you absolutely
have the right to make that argument
okay
where does it say that in here or where
does that say that in 458 or
um any
any other statute well it doesn't
because what you're doing is you're
making an argument to the court in other
words if a judge so in other words
here's the way this would typically play
out
one party submits a proposed order or
recites a set of circumstances that they
want the court to take a certain action
but it is always the government's burden
and this burden never shifts to an
individual okay under well-settled law
to justify actions that violate the
constitution this is always a government
burden it is never ever on a party
okay
uh that's the that's the history of
constitutional law when the when the
government or court infringes on a right
so to answer your question directly
representative long
uh the court says i'm going to do what i
am going to for one of a better term i
am going to place content-based
restrictions okay on what you say to him
or to her or whatever i'm going to do
that you cannot talk about this you
cannot talk about that you cannot talk
about this and then
if it's in there and the and the party
is aware of it and hopefully that would
be in the statute because one of the key
portions of the statute is to give
reasonable notice uh to a little to a
party as to what the law is
that's well settled law so they come in
and they say but your honor i have
constitutional rights and by the way
your honor i see that under this statute
if you're infringing on my
constitutional rights
uh can you please tell me why you're
doing it
and why there is no less restrictive way
and then it would be up to the court to
justify the restriction to your question
a follow-up
yes represent follow-up
thank you uh now with the newly added uh
constitutional right of privacy to the
hampshire's constitution
um
i
i would suspect that that could be tied
into anything you're
you're asking me to do
um whether or not you
um
you're compelling me to
uh release whatever income although
that's in another statute
but my mother pays for my oil heat and
that's
you're asking me for that
um do you see a potential um
do you see a potential um
[Music]
you know added burden
with respect to the right of privacy in
in these
you know in these infringements um
no because remember this first of all
there's no undue burden on a court this
is actually handled in a few sentences
uh
and that's not hard to do the other
thing is is that i don't see a right of
privacy here let me explain
uh
that's governed differently okay uh and
that's governed by different statutes
for example uh
financial affidavits when filed with the
court become confidential as a matter of
law uh that is not an enumerated right
under the federal or state constitutions
uh this is actually fairly narrow okay
and it uh i hope i'm answering your
question representative long yeah
if i may uh look for the follow-up yeah
just just i mean maybe that was a bad
example i'm thinking of um
uh my
my right to have a gun in my room and to
me that's my private belonging and
that's my privacy that i want to keep
you have that yeah i'm sorry go ahead
and and i'm being compelled to uh
divulge that
okay uh that doesn't infringe on your
second amendment right i mean that's a
good question and i'm going to try to
answer it as best i can first of all let
me restate
this does not apply to domestic violence
petitions okay this does not apply to
domestic violence orders which by the
way cut across a wide swath of
constitutional rights and they are
necessary to achieve a compelling
government interest so this doesn't
doesn't apply there okay
if you want to have a gun in your house
that's the second amendment that's your
right to keep and bear arms assuming you
are under no legal disability to do so
okay uh could a court for example
issue orders with respect to firearms
actually they probably could
if
uh it was somehow necessary to protect
the best interests of a child for
example and this is by the way you're
you know you're asking a great question
here okay so let's look at the two
rights
um
first in terms of parenting in the best
interest of the child remember that we
always have that
okay because protecting a child from
danger is a compelling government
interest at the same time we have a
conflict we say that um representative
long says i own a gun the judge you
can't take away my gun rights no you're
not you can keep and bear but a time
place and manner restriction
would be considered valid and not
subject to an enumerated right for
example
a court issues an order because guns are
an issue in this case for some reason
i'll give you a hypothetical
judge
opposing party here leaves guns laying
around the house loaded
okay i'm seeking an order
to prevent
uh the other side here from leaving guns
laying around loaded because they have
parenting time and this is a
five-year-old child who may get into a
gun and hurt himself okay so if i'm the
judge okay i am going to
if it's a second and then representative
long says but your honor i have a second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
and uh if i'm the judge
i'm gonna say you do have a second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
however i have a competing interest here
which is the best interest of the child
okay and so if i have to infringe
upon a my and by the way it would be a
mild infringement okay uh
on your right to keep and bear your
right to keep and bear does not extend
to leaving a loaded gun laying around
the house where a five-year-old can get
it okay so i am going to say that this
would be necessary to achieve a
compelling government interest if i'm
the judge i'm going to rule as follows
i'm going to say
the
party in question here asserts a second
amendment right to keep and bear arms
but i hear credible evidence that the
party who asserts the second amendment
right leaves a loaded gun around the
house where a child might be able to
access it
okay to preserve the best interests of
the child i make the following ruling
i'm going to say that i recognize that a
second amendment right exists
however this does not
me meaningfully infringe on the right to
keep and bear but it's necessary to
protect the best interest of the child
for him to keep
the loaded gun
out of reach or safely stored while
exercising parenting time or while the
child is in the house okay and there's
no less restrictive way for me to do it
that's my order as a court okay and
that's a good example and thank you for
giving me a fabulous example of why
these statutes are necessary
hey thank you attorney michael thank you
madam chair
oh welcome representative uh next we
have a representative alt shiller seems
to have a question do you
you can unmute yourself and ask your
question
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
attorney marco for answering my question
um
uh it's
delightful to hear
um
some
sense being uh brought to the brought to
the new hampshire legislature
about um
gun violence prevention so for for that
i thank you very much
but i don't know i'm not sure how that
necessarily applies to this bill you
used an example
um in your testimony of someone being
barred from being able to practice their
religion because of a restraining order
and i don't know that that's did you
have examples of that ever happening in
new hampshire that seems rather extreme
well no what i uh i respectfully will
restate representative about schuler
thank you okay when you look at the
restraining orders i'm going to respon
uh i'm going to point out rsa45816
and i'm going to
first and i'm going to say when you take
a look at rsa45816
and i'm going to say 458 16 1
b
c
and d and when you look at b
in joining okay you have in joining any
party from entering the premises wherein
the other party resides upon a showing
of physical or emotional harm would
result in joining and then c
in joining any party from contacting the
other party or entering the other
party's place of employment or school
and then below that in joining any party
from harassing intimidating or
threatening the other party or other
parties relatives regardless of their
place of residences or other parties
household members in any way now
why
if we respect the constitution if
there's no respect for the constitution
why wouldn't we
add this language and say in joining any
party from
uh entering the place of employment or
where the other party worships
because if you're dead
because what happens if somebody else
worships there as well
so in other words that's an implicit
recognition that that's freedom of
religion
okay now it creates a different dynamic
under other circumstances but if there
were no respect for that why would we
have it now we have practically an
identical track on rsa 461 810 which
also says 461 a 10 1
okay b and c which basically track the
same language uh entering the premises
enter contacting or entering the other
party's place of employment or school
once again no restriction on attending
church or synagogue or any other place
of worship
okay may i follow up madam chair
follow up yes
sure um actually want to go in a
different direction i i thank you for
your thoughts on
on that interpretation um but i'd like
to go to
the actual
language of the bill okay and on on
lines
six
basically from the word identify on line
five
all the way to the word objective on
line seven
okay it appears that this
is uh this bill is
intent on creating a
formula
and perhaps even a form
um for
judges to fill out
that would have to
you know would create a you know a very
um
specific way of giving orders rather
than their thoughtful narratives
um
and that seems like that would be that's
the sacrifice that is
being asked is that you're taking away
judicial discretion and judicial
um
creativity in the way that they're
applying the law
um and making them fill out a form
uh no actually not what this is is that
this simply goes right into the
narrative any judge sitting in this
state should have taken constitutional
law or should be familiar with it as a
matter of going to law school okay
number one number two is is that this
language actually tracks well settled
united states supreme court
constitutional law which is called
strict scrutiny strict scrutiny comes
and this is basically what this law is
okay this is this is where it comes from
i did not invent this uh in fact if you
look at the case i submitted called the
shock case okay you're gonna find strict
scrutiny in there okay because this is
well settled law i didn't create this
okay uh and so it's simply a test and it
says
what's the necessary if i'm gonna
infringe on a constitutional right
the narrative is going to be something
like this and it goes right the the
order would be something like this and
goes right into the court's narrative
it's going to be
petitioner
seeks
a b c d e f g that they not be allowed
to fill in the blank not be allowed to
discuss
uh
uh the child with third parties uh
not be allowed to whatever i
grant this
noting that the first amendment
does blank and has what's called prior
restraint okay however based on the
facts of this case which infringes which
may mildly infringe on a right however i
find as follows one the parties have a
history of blank
two the party
in question for whom this restriction
applies has a history which is
unchallenged of blank
the compelling interest here
is
that to protect or whatever okay to
protect the interests of a child or
protect whatever it is which is a
compelling government interest
and number four
there is no
having considered all the options
there is no less restrictive way of
achieving this compelling government
interest
okay and that is the supreme court test
um and you'll see it in the shock case
okay that i i emailed to the committee
because that's a very good recital of
first amendment now most of the
violations i think that
in terms of orders and constitutional
infringement that occurs
occurs in the first amendment context
either within a restraining order
context or outside of it okay and what
you have here
in your present statute is is that we
are telling the courts
okay on what i referenced before
we are telling the courts that guess
what
the constitution really doesn't apply to
you
okay that there is a family law
exception to the federal and state
constitutions when in fact there is no
such exception
that's my point in dealing with this so
this is curative
um
representative out shoulder have i
answered your question
um i have the information i need thank
you okay
thank you uh any further questions
thank you mr marquel
my pleasure
our next person who would like to
testify is aaron justina
aaron you can unmute yourself
great can you hear me
yes
okay thank you
good morning madam chair and members of
the committee my name is aaron justina
and i direct the domestic violence
advocacy project at new hampshire legal
assistance
for more than 20 years the domestic
violence project has been representing
victims and survivors of domestic
violence sexual assault and stalking in
their protective order cases as well as
their high lethality divorce and
parenting cases i'm here today to
testify in opposition to house bill 494
with respect i'm still very unclear as
to the issue this bill seeks to correct
um which constitutional rights exactly
have been infringed upon by utilizing
this type of restraining order
and right now we're talking about the
restraining under restraining orders
under
rsa
458-16 so under the divorce statute
um
attorney markel provided some very
nuanced examples where half of the
action by the court is permissible in
his opinion but the other half is not if
this bill were to become law i'm not
sure how judges would even apply it this
is exactly a solution looking for a
problem
the language of this bill is far too
technical for the average person
accessing the family court to understand
as practitioners even we reviewed this
bill and had difficulty pinpointing the
objective and the process for which that
objective would be achieved
so these restraining orders the ones
that we're talking about today we're
talking about restraining orders under
the marital statute and under the
parental rights and responsibilities
statute so these types of restraining
orders are less restrictive
than other civil protective orders and i
think that may be causing some of the
confusion
so orders
these orders can be used in cases where
perhaps the party doesn't qualify for a
protective order under rsa 173b which is
the domestic violence statue or simply
doesn't want the protections offered
under that statute but it is clear
something needs to be in place to act as
a buffer between the parties in a
particularly high conflict case or even
in a case involving domestic violence
this type of restraining order is often
used to settle cases
again one party may be willing to forego
a domestic violence protective order in
exchange for a marital or parenting
restraining order if it means settling
their divorce or parenting case
so again i
understand
that the intent was to
um
create clarification around these types
of restraining orders um but based on
the testimony today based on our reading
of the proposed language of the proposed
bill i think it's going to create
further confusion and again this bill is
seeking a solution to a problem that
does not currently exist so therefore we
respectfully requested this committee
vote in expedient to legislate on house
bill 494 thank you
thank you miss justina any questions for
mr cena
seeing none will go to the next person
uh asking to speak representative
albert baldessara
uh thank you madam chair um
for the record representative al
baldassau rockingham county district
five which is londonderry
um i am calling in support of hb 494 and
i was honored to co-sponsor this bill
uh nine out of ten cases of um
restraining orders uh the person
that the restraining order is against
doesn't even know until the cops show up
to his door
and say you have to leave and then ten
days you get a hearing
um
the rights uh people's rights are being
abused because within that 10-day period
guns are taken away uh depending on the
issue and the court order from the judge
and um you know you're removed and
and i've said on many cases here i'm one
of the original representatives uh on
the redress caucus
and we've heard cases of uh over
religious cases where one parent wanted
the kid to go
back to the religious school and the
other parent that had the custody didn't
want it uh there are many cases out
there that rights are being abused now
how do i know this here because i'm a
victim of one myself
okay on a restraining order didn't know
anything until the police showed up and
said i have to leave a house
i was fortunate to fight it i got it
dismissed and got custody of my
um daughter um in a divorce case
children are used as political pawns and
all it takes is for a parent to go
and say that they fear for their life
and a restraining order is issued
this is a no-brainer
this legislation the system needs to be
fixed and i want to thank
the chairman for bringing this bill
forward because
it's going to fix something that is
broken in the family court we all know
that and there is a bunch of us
legislators that sat in family courts
and watched and heard and seen what goes
on on these restraining orders
um so i thank you uh for bringing this
forward and i was honored to co-sponsor
thank you
thank you representative baldassaro
representative altschiller has a
question for you will you take it
i sure would
thank you you cannot mute yourself
representative
thank you madam chair and
thank you representative baldassaro for
entertaining a question
um
i
i'm curious because i think that
have you
possibly
mixed up the two different kinds of
restraining orders because um
what what is what we've been talking
about is is not
a restraining order that would remove
someone from a house
um nor take away their firearms we're
we're talking about parenting plans
um
so
is it
is it possible that maybe this is this
is not
this is not that bill
not at all because when you take away a
parenting plan you're actually taking
away other rights because you've moved
out of the house
uh and i know it firsthand because i was
involved with the parenting plan
uh but it took me 10 days of being out
of a house and everything else and
losing a lot of my rights
until i got back into court and got it
dismissed
mayor thank you
follow up
so
this bill
this bill would only
this bill seeks to compel judges
to clarify
why they are doing what they are doing
in a detailed in a detailed way
and
yeah so i don't understand
how i don't understand how you're
conflating
taking away um
firearms from someone who is a danger to
themselves or their family and
deemed to have to have that
that process taken
with this bill that
is asking the government to explain that
in great detail so
there's no police involvement unless
someone is actually committing a crime
is there a question in there
the question is do you understand that
this is no invol police involvement
unless there is a crime
uh that's any any type of restraining
order the police are involved because
they go to your house and deliver it
there was no crime in my case it's just
somebody with fear for life that goes to
the court and says that i have a problem
then a parental plan is taken put in
place
and you're moved out of the house um
so i don't understand where you're going
with that there because it's a it's
happening all the time
you know with the parental plans to a um
you know a restraining order
thank you any further questions
thank you representative baldassaro
thank you
have a good day
thank you you as well
the next person we have to testify is mr
richard head
thank you madam chair thank you members
of the committee my name is richard head
i'm the government affairs coordinator
for the judicial branch
um i think there is a a fundamental
misunderstanding
as to
what the statute allows
because the statute does not create an
exception to the constitution
the legislative body cannot
create a statutory exception to
constitutional rights
so there's nothing in the current
statute that
expands a judge's rights relative to the
constitutional rights of the people in
front of that judge
so you know i think there's a
fundamental premise that is that is not
the case a judge
is still bound by the constitution and
if a statute is unconstitutional this uh
the court would have to find that the
statute is unconstitutional then simply
cannot apply it
um or would have to extract out the
unconstitutional provisions of the of
the
statute the other aspect of the bill
that i think is um
is
is inaccurate is that it applies
it talks as to strict scrutiny which is
uh as attorney markell stated
one of the
ways in which you review constitutional
provisions and for some constitutional
provisions
strict scrutiny is the appropriate
level of review but there are in fact
three levels of scrutiny relative to
constitutional provisions and it depends
entirely upon the circumstances in the
in the constitutional provision involved
uh and the bill as written does not
limit
the review to or the issue to the first
amendment
but talks about
all constitutional provisions state and
federal and there are in fact three
tiers of review strict scrutiny
intermediate scrutiny and rational basis
scrutiny depending on the constitutional
provision involved
so this would
this would actually create a standard
for all constitutional provisions that
would apply the strict scrutiny uh
standard which is which is not
constitutional law
and then my final point is that this
does not change anything
the courts are still bound by the
constitution
the the court's decisions are subject to
review as would occur under this under
this bill
uh and if the supreme court makes a
determination that a ruling was
unconstitutional
in in in in similar to the the decision
that attorney markell provided you the
shack massachusetts decision it applies
the same way in new hampshire the
supreme court
evaluates the decision
determines whether or not a
constitutional provision has been
violated and if so whether or not under
the one of the three appropriate tiers
of scrutiny whether there was a basis
for which
that could occur so there's nothing in
current law in the legislature is not
authorized through current law
judges to violate the constitution
and in fact this bill as written
would
incorrectly apply level of scrutiny
relative to various constitutional
provisions
uh given the breadth of of the
of the bill um
so ai test try for information but i i
think there are some
at the foundation of the of the proposal
some misunderstandings uh and i would be
happy to answer any questions thank you
thank you mr head
any questions
seeing none thank you very much mr
hedgehog
um and we will close this hearing
we had uh one in support
uh three opposed and two testified
and we will close this
and i'll give the clerk a minute to get
things together when she nods her head
we will go on to
uh house bill 495.
sorry madam chair we actually had four
people testify
i apologize i was reading from my sheet
yes
and the sheets are not always updated i
stand corrected thank you representative
all children yeah i know you get
understood first thing in the morning
right
right and then people raise their hands
that haven't signed in so yes we did
have four
thank you representative alastair we
will now open the
next hearing
house bill 495
i am the sponsor so i will read the bill
and we will move on from there thank
you this bill provides that the court
shall not
issue an order in a parenting case that
infringes upon a party's constitutional
rights unless the court determines there
is no less restrictive means to achieve
a compelling government interest
and with that i will be happy to turn
the testimony over to
mr markel
mr marquel you can unmute yourself
hi can you hear me
yes we can now thank you mr martin go
ahead to the previous testimony i'm well
aware of the three levels of
constitutional review there is what's
called rational basis there is what's
called intermediate scrutiny and there's
what's called strict scrutiny what we're
talking about here is this strict
scrutiny and the reason why is because
if it infringes on a right now bear in
mind okay a couple of things number one
is is that rational basis says that all
it has to do
is
is basically for economic and social
legislation okay so in other words
is it constitutional to regulate certain
kinds of businesses we heard from the
judiciary so let's discuss what these
levels of review are and try to keep it
real and try to keep it meaningful okay
number one rational basis review under
the constitution is things like economic
and social legislation okay economic and
social legislation is can they issue for
example a business require you to have a
business license to give
to open a business the answer is yes can
they require barbers to have licenses
and pass levels of competency to get
that the answer is yes can government
regulate certain businesses uh at to
certain extents and that gets rational
basis review in other words is it
connected to a rational government
objective
intermediate level of scrutiny okay are
things like uh time place and manner
restrictions okay so in other words when
you
say
you have visitation in a parenting class
in a parenting program okay you have
this level of visitation it's on
weekends it's this and that okay for
example or better yet um in terms of
speech and parades you have to get a
permit okay uh to manifest your right of
free speech you can your parade permit
is good for
x days or x hours between this and this
and this okay those are time place and
manner restrictions and they get a
lesser uh more deferential standard of
review what we're talking about here are
things like content based restrictions
that's prior okay that constitutes prior
restraint when a court says so in other
words
when and judges should be familiar with
this
so when you hear so when somebody says
you can't tell me that i can't talk on
this time place or manner restriction
the court simply says okay this is a
time place and manner restriction and
it's not subject to this kind of review
okay uh what we're talking about is
things like content-based regulation and
things like that
so i understand what i heard before but
those are basically the three levels of
review that we're talking about uh
number one this does not constitute a
burden on on the court system at all uh
judges should understand it um
if
what i'm saying here is is that you have
and what i'll restate in 461 a10 is is
that you have such conditions and
limitations as a court may deem just
okay now
the practical aspects are
that um courts will say yes i can and by
the way in terms of it being a problem a
solution looking for a problem uh
perhaps i should redax heavily some
orders so that you should see them
because uh
you know eliminating courts eliminating
judge names and eliminating parties
because i have the orders so this is a
problem and it's not just a solution
looking for a problem
uh
you know i would want to check further
to see if that's permissible but these
are the kinds of things that are out
there um
and the other thing is is that the
notion that you can be able to go to the
supreme court and get things adjusted
okay as a practical matter this provides
a standard of review
okay so in other words um judge this is
what happened in the case were my
constitutional rights violated so in
other words was there an error of law
involved which is a different standard
of review from the unsustainable
exercise of discretion to the prejudice
of of a um
of a uh
of a litigant uh
that's basically where we're at um this
is i think a mild i think this is a mild
remedy it doesn't tell courts that they
can't do things all they simply have to
do is justify it if a court disagrees
and said this does not apply this simply
calls upon the court to exercise the
knowledge that it should that it ought
to have
um as far as it once again we heard from
new hampshire legal assistance we
respect their positions but this is not
a domestic violence issue it simply
isn't domestic violence travels under
its own authority with its own levels of
protections um this is simply an uh
a protection of constitutional this is
simply a vehicle by which courts and
parties get notice of constitutional
rights and are able to aggravate and be
able to explain their orders that's it
thank you mr markell any questions
seeing none we will go on to the next
person who wishes to testify and i'll
call upon aaron justina
justina i apologize
uh
erin you can unmute yourself
okay thank you and no worries
um
uh again my name is aaron justina i
direct the domestic violence advocacy
project at new hampshire legal
assistance
and madam chair with your permission um
house bill 494 and 495 are
nearly ident they are identical they're
just placed in two different statutes so
my testimony would be the same for 494
as well as 4.95 so in the interest of
time
i will not reiterate that testimony if
that's all right with you madam chair
but i i do just have two follow-up
points
i'm perfectly fine with whatever you
want to do your testimony is important
so it's totally up to you how you want
to testify thank you
hopefully everyone will remember 494. so
i will just reiterate that testimony um
but i do want to clarify um and respond
to attorney markell's
position that this is not a domestic
violence issue it is a domestic violence
issue um we heard from a representative
who um said that these types of
restraining orders
um remove people from the home and guns
are removed and that is simply not the
case um respectfully that is not the
case um i believe what he is referring
to is um
protections that are reported a victim
under rsa
173b or under the stalking statute which
is rsa 633
3a
so in those situations where a domestic
violence victim goes to court and files
a petition
and the court issues a temporary order
in that situation
then yes
um if guns were involved if there are
guns in the home or other weapons in the
home
in that situation yes a police officer
is going to show up at the house is
going to remove the person from the home
and is going to remove those weapons
that is absolutely what happens under
those two statutes that is not what is
happening in this situation
guns are not removed
you're not removed from your home
unless as representative alt shiller
commented
you are not getting arrested for
violating this restraining order unless
you are committing a crime which you
would be arrested for anyway
um so if somebody assaults someone
regardless of whether or not there's
this type of restraining order in place
or another type you're getting arrested
because you committed a crime um this is
a civil restraining order um
again
police involvement
is not happening unless you are in fact
committing a crime
if you violate
a um
restraining under restraining order
under 458 16 or under 461 a
you're dealing with a contempt motion in
court
so i wanted to address that point but
also to attorney mark hill's point that
it's not a domestic violence issue
um
these restraining orders as i mentioned
in my earlier testimony are often used
in settling domestic violence cases or i
should say domestic violence involve
divorce or parenting cases
so as i mentioned um you may have a
victim who does not wish to seek um an
order under 173b
there are many reasons why a victim may
choose not to do that
perhaps she doesn't want to
have another court involved case
perhaps does not want to share the very
very intimate details of a sexual
assault
perhaps does not want to access that
protection because it may escalate the
abuse by her abuser
it could increase her lethality risk
so an alternative for a domestic
violence victim is to get one of these
restraining orders in a divorce and
parenting case one of these restraining
orders which yes
perhaps less well is less restrictive
will be the deterrent
for that abuser to leave the victim
alone and to cease the abuse
um so i respectfully disagree that these
are not domestic violence related um
restraining orders they they are we use
them in cases
to resolve cases to settle cases for our
clients that don't want to go through
the 173b process but wants something in
place to make the abuse stop
um and and these do that to some extent
um
so for those reasons and for the
testimony that i offered under house
bill 494
i respectfully request that this
committee return a vote of inexpedient
to legislate
thank you for your time and i'm happy to
take any questions
thank you miss jacina
do i see any questions
seeing none oh i'm sorry representative
lewicki
thank you madam chair and thank you uh
mr zena um
i am trying to understand why
how your testimony applies to this bill
whether it's a domestic violence order
or any other order what reason could
there possibly be for not putting in a
constitutional justification
i
i'm not exactly sure how these um
how the language of this bill is
infringing on somebody's constitutional
rights and i think it's the language of
this bill that is confusing as i stated
in my earlier testimony just the plain
language of this bill is not accessible
to the general public i think it's going
to be
difficult to apply
you heard mr head testify um for the
reasons that and i will um agree with
his testimony in response to that
question
follow-up um thank you madam chair
um
i am
a college dropout and i have no
difficulty reading this language
why would you assert that somebody
isn't able to understand it it looks
like plain english to me
um
respectfully i will answer your question
um that most people have a
very um
low grade reading level um i think like
the average is somewhere around middle
school or high school and so you're
having
general public accessing and people who
don't speak any english at all
low-income
people seeking
services or
justice through our family court system
and trying to review our laws these are
not easy to read they're not accessible
and the language of this bill is not
accessible so um
i appreciate that the reading to you is
very plain
it is not to me
thank you mr cena anyone else have any
questions
seeing no further questions we'll move
on to the next person who wishes to
testify mr richard had
um
thank you uh madam chair uh thank you
members of the committee my name is
richard head i'm the government affairs
coordinator for the judicial branch um
and thank you for giving me the
opportunity to testify again as was
stated this is very similar to the last
bill but i'll repeat myself a little bit
and i apologize
the bill would provide that
the court has to identify
any rights
being infringed under any enumerated
federal or state constitutional
provision
and as i said
before there are three levels of
scrutiny depending on
which constitutional enumerated
constitutional provision is is being is
at issue
it could be strict scrutiny which is
specifically identified in the bill
there's intermediate scrutiny and
there's rational basis
this would provide
that all
orders issued under 173 b
if there is a potential infringement on
a constitutional right would have to
uh be subject to stroke scrutiny which
is which is simply not the standard for
all provisions
secondly there is it does not accomplish
anything that is not already
current in existing law as i said with
regard to the other bill um the statute
that's
targeted here rsa 173 b
does not create any exceptions to the
constitution the legislature is simply
not authorized to create exceptions to
the constitution and is not authorized
to give judges authority to violate
constitutional provisions the judges are
always subject to the constitution
and so any time
a court whether
due to the fact that a particular area
of law is not
uh well described
so so the court needs the supreme court
needs to issue
a ruling for the first time relative to
the constitutional authority to issue a
type of order
or that the court has already the
supreme court has already described
when certain limitations
are constitutionally authorized
that already exists in in current law
and and as the last sentence of the bill
says any party aggrieved by an order not
meeting the standard may petition the
court to have the order modified or
vacated anytime
if for whatever reason a constitutional
right is infringed upon by a court's
order the party always has the right to
seek reconsideration of that order or to
appeal to the supreme court in the
supreme court on a constitutional issue
uh does not
look at it as an unsustainable exercise
of discretion standard
but looks at all constitutional issues
new and and bases it on its own review
not upon the trial court's review
so there is no difference in the sense
of how the supreme court looks at
constitutional issues with or without
regard to this bill
um so as with regard to the other
uh the last bill that we heard you know
the the foundation for the the reason
behind this bill
simply does not exist
and with that i'd be happy to take any
questions thank you very much
thank you mr head
representative lewicki do you have a
question yes thank you madam chair and
uh thank you mr head
so
i believe what i hear you telling me and
please tell me if it's not is that uh
while someone appeals their rights to
the supreme court those rights will be
held in abeyance
is that correct
not always um so if an order can be
stayed pending review
either by the trial court's order or by
the supreme court's order so not
necessarily
thank you any further questions
seeing none
i will thank mr head for his testimony
and i will read the sheet
according to my sheet and what i have
added up and i will ask representative
all children off schiller to correct me
if i'm wrong
we had one in support three opposed and
a total of four to testify
and with that i will close the hearing
on house bill 495
and give the clerk a minute or so
to
finish up her work and then we'll move
on
to house bill 120.
madam vice chair
yes madam clerk
if i could please ask people when
they're introducing themselves to also
add if they have
a written testimony
i have quite a few pages of notes from
persons i do have many um
written testimonies printed out that's
why you see me running back and forth
um
but if they have written testimony it
will alleviate some of the
writings that i'm doing
thank you madam clerk i will try in my
brain to remember to ask them for that
okay thank you
thank you
are you ready
thank you madam clerk
uh the next bill i'd like to open is
house bill 120
relative to the administration of
psychotropic medications to children in
foster care
i
see that
um
i don't have that sheet
this bill
is sponsored by representative marsh
and i see that he's here
representative marsh you can
unmute yourself and begin testimony
uh thank you madam chair
and thank you for hearing house bill 120
today as the clerk requested i did
submit my testimony
to the committee by email so she doesn't
have to write down everything that i say
and i also attached some supporting
documents which you guys may want to uh
consider here too
record i'm representative of william
marsh carroll county eight representing
seven towns in southern carroll county
and i'm pleased to bring you today house
bill 120 relative to the use of
psychotropic medications for children in
foster care
this bill was filed in response to the
united states inspector general's
september 2018 report treatment planning
and medication monitoring were lacking
for children in foster care receiving
psychotropic medication
which i've also emailed to the committee
for the permanent record
note especially page 23 which summarizes
specifics relevant to new hampshire and
which i also emailed to you separately
for convenience
what the office of the inspector general
did is to review medicaid claims data
and clinical records in the five states
which reported the highest percentage of
children in foster care receiving
psychotropic medications
new hampshire had the third highest
it did this because the administration
for children and families is responsible
for awarding federal funding to state's
child welfare programs and for
overseeing those programs
and they reminded us on page three of
their report that if acf finds that a
state is not in substantial conformity
with its state plan
it has the authority to withhold a
certain amount of federal funding
what the inspector general found is that
23.4 percent of new hampshire children
in foster care receiving psychotropic
medications had no treatment plan
37.9 percent had a treatment plan but no
diagnosis on their treatment plan
as a doctor i am most troubled that the
total of these numbers is 61.3 percent
meaning
that the majority of the kids in new
hampshire foster care receiving
psychotropic medications had no
diagnosis
and 21.8 percent of these children did
not receive medication monitoring by a
prescribing professional
house bill 120 is actually a pretty
simple bill
last year with house bill 1278 which was
similar which you guys sent to interim
study there was an objection to the
department using rulemaking to limit the
use of psychotropic drugs
in house bill 120 we defined medication
restraint as the use of psychotropic
drugs without a clinical diagnosis and
apply the existing law in rsa 126u
to such use
medication restraint is specifically
referenced in rsa 126u
colon 1 roman 4.
so long as medical practitioners are
treating disease
or in other words list the diagnosis
this will never apply to legitimate
medical treatment
this is similar to how we limited the
use of psychotropic medications as a
restraint
in hospitals and nursing homes a
generation ago
california passed a similar bill
tightening oversight over the use of
psychotropic medications in foster care
in 2015 and it has resulted in a 45
percent reduction in antipsychotic
prescriptions to foster care kids
and a 73 percent reduction in
prescriptions for multiple psychotropic
drugs
the inspector general on page 31 of his
report said that new hampshire spent one
million seven hundred and forty one
thousand five hundred and eighty one
dollars for psychotropic medications for
foster kids in 2016.
while this bill lacks a fiscal note i
would contend that a similar 45 percent
reduction in new hampshire would result
in a 783 thousand
uh 711 dollar savings to the new
hampshire budget
i also sent you amendment 0517h
which addresses specific concerns
brought forward by the new hampshire
psychiatric society i'm sure they will
speak to their uh
word language changes and in my opinion
it improves the bill without undermining
my intent
so thank you and i will be glad to
answer questions
thank you representative marsh do i see
any questions
seeing none i thank you very much for
your time and introducing this bill and
bringing it to our attention
thank you
that said i will now close the hearing
on
house bill 120.
um
is that for 120
i don't have that sheet okay i apologize
i'm not closing
the hearing on that bill i'm reopening
it and
uh
i see
moira o'neil child advocate
who would like to testify good morning
moira
good morning can you hear me okay madam
chair
yes great good morning madam chair and
uh members of the committee um for the
record my name is moira o'neil and i'm
the state child advocate i appreciate
the opportunity to speak in support of
house bill 120 relative to the
administration of psychotropic
medications to children in foster care
we're very grateful to representative
marsh for raising this bill it's a very
important issue
we support it and we did work with new
hampshire psychiatric society
to craft a few suggested amendments to
the bill
but as he said it doesn't change it it
just um and strengthens it and
protecting children
he has already referenced the inspector
general's report which i think is very
important
to note and to guide this conversation
children in dcyf custody are
predominantly children who are victims
of abuse neglect or other family
dysfunction
that causes a high level of adverse
childhood experiences
and aces are associated with mental
illness communication disorders um that
often manifest as problem behaviors and
generally removal from their homes is a
response to the need for safety
but treatment that's prompted by the
persistent symptoms of this mental
illness or problem behaviors um tends to
be um often more medication focused than
and then otherwise and so it's really
important to be thinking about how we
protect kids when they're receiving
these medications anecdotally
the office of the child advocate has
reviewed a number of children's cases in
which
problematic changes in the child's
behavior appear primarily addressed by
medication changes and in some of those
cases we've seen it later discovered
that there were manifested behaviors
that were caused by other underlying
physical conditions so we're really very
concerned about not just monitoring
the use of psychotropic medication but
also monitoring children's health in
general
so some of the
of the recommended changes that that
we've brought forward
would first of all amend the definition
of medication restraint
um to make put the proposal in hb 120
consistent with the definition of
medication restraint already in rsa
chapter 126u
and for that we would say change the
language to medication restraint is
defined as the involuntary
administration of any medication
including psychotropic medication
without a clinical diagnosis for the
purpose of controlling behavior unless
it is to ensure the immediate physical
safety of persons when there's
substantial or imminent risk of serious
bodily harm to children
we also suggest amending the title of
rsa 169b section 23 on page 1
line 9
to orders for health examination and
treatment
and the term physical treatment as used
on page 1 lines 10 to 11 to health
treatment
those are language changes but they what
they do is they change
to encompass both physical and mental
health treatment as i referenced you
before sometimes behavior change isn't a
psychological problem it's an underlying
physical issue
so we want to make sure that we're
comprehensively assessing children um
and also addressing the stigma that's
associated with mental health treatment
caused by separating physical and mental
health out it's all health for children
we further recommend that prior to
prescribing psychotropic medications the
prescribing provider should first ensure
two assessments are or have been
recently conducted one is a
comprehensive medical
assessment to rule out any physical
organic condition underlying the
symptoms that the medication is intended
to treat and that will ensure the
holistic approach um effective
diagnostics and treatment and also
minimize the exposure to unnecessary
psychotropic medications
and the next thing we recommend in terms
of assessment is a comprehensive
psychosocial assessment and a plan and
implemented evidence-based treatments
accordingly
especially in the cases of young
children the professional consensus is
to address psychosocial issues prior to
or at least in concert with prescribing
medications
additionally
because of the unfortunate trends in
inconsistency of placement of children
children's health care is not always
consistently followed by any one
provider or parent like proxy
unfortunately in this state
we feel that when a child sees a
provider
who prescribes psychotropic medications
the consultation should include the
child's guardian and a dcyf nurse to
ensure that they're aware and informed
of the reason for the medication the
therapeutic intention of the medication
and any potential side effects that
should be monitored we also suggest that
the bill include the expectation that
any child in foster care whose
prescribed psychotropic medications will
be referred to a dcyf district office
nurse for their monitoring of care and
provision of informational support and
guidance to the field staff and to the
caregivers of the child this provides
for some consistent oversight if
children are moving around and seeing
different providers
um to incorporate those suggestions we
recommend adding the following language
and i have i have submitted written
testimony to you um that has the pages
and lines in them so i'll leave that out
but that's just um in the interest of
time it's there where we would change
that language we also
recommend um an amendment in terms of
the duties of the impart of the
department to ensure that dcy of
district office nurses provide
medication monitoring for children in
foster care that's more language there
there's no distinction in this bill
about who prescribes psychotropic
medication to children in foster care
and that's actually okay because the
flexibility is necessary as you probably
all know
there's a chronic shortage of child
psychiatrists in new hampshire
but if we're codifying the use of
psychotropic medications it would be
neglectful not to be sure that anyone
prescribing medications has access to
expertise and guidance to make the best
decisions for children
there's an excellent model several
excellent models of support for primary
care pediatricians
who are willing to prescribe
psychotropic medications with adequate
support and guidance
i direct your attention to the
massachusetts child psychiatry access
project which is one of those model that
provides a remote consultation and
educational supports on best practices
to primary care pediatricians
dcyf currently contracts with dartmouth
hitchcock
for services of a psychiatrist at the
sununu youth services center
and because the uh the census has been
so low there he's actually had time to
do some consultations on medication
reviews of some of children across the
state
so his contract's not adequate to
provide the level of support that we're
thinking of to pediatric providers but
it certainly is a start maybe something
that could evolve into a program like
the massachusetts program that i i
recommend
so we suggest that being added in
and finally centralized oversight of
children's care is essential
to identify trends across child
experience
and so
the bill calls for reporting to the
joint legislative oversight committee on
health and human services
and we have found that reports that go
to legislative committees are sometimes
not always consistently monitored just
because of you know the unfortunateness
of a two-year term in the legislation in
the legislature
so we recommend that in addition to that
report
pathway that it also
um be sent to the office of the child
advocate um so that we can do some
consistent monitoring um of the reports
and report back to the committees as
well um we've started doing that
with
looking at restraints and seclusion
that's reported to committees we're
finding that it's very helpful to have
someone who's actually monitoring and
analyzing data that's coming in
i have also provided for your
information at the bottom of my written
testimony
some details about the side effects of
psychotropic medications just so that
you have some awareness of that
these drugs can really change lives they
can be very helpful but they are also
you know dangerous in in children's
brains when they're not used um
appropriately so it's important to
really understand the impact of them um
and i'll stop there and thank you for
taking my testimony i welcome your
questions if you have them
thank you um
i
see a question from representative
lewicky
thank you madam chair and thank you ms
o'neill
do you know whether dcyf has the
resources to implement this which would
be nurses and so forth
um thank you for that question and i'm
happy to answer that in the last
biennium budget there there was funding
for nursing positions
they're not all filled yet but they are
in the process of hiring them and we're
really pleased for that dcyf had nurses
in the past um and they were lost in the
last 10 years but they're back and
that's a really good role for them when
children have special medical needs that
um that they're there to not just
monitor the individual child but also to
give guidance to caseworkers who often
are involved in decision making and
guidance to the caregivers whether
they're foster parents or um or for
biological parents who are in the
process of reunifying who need to really
understand medications that their
children are receiving
thank you
thank you next uh question is uh
representative blanchard
uh thank you madam chair um and thank
you maura
for uh attending our committee hearing
today um you alluded to a low number of
students at the sysc center um and just
for curiosity's sake how many students
is that
um thank you for that question
representative belanger i believe today
the census is around 12.
it's been in the last few months eight
to ten
i think the average for the year dcyf is
reporting is about 24 but we've seen
consistently you know under around
hovering around 10 and i would say the
last eight months or so
thank you no fault
thank you next we have representative
long you have a question
thank you madam chair thank you miss
o'neill for your testimony a couple
questions on the uh
in the amendment
uh
it asks for um it asks for consultation
with the child's caregiver is does that
does that include the foster care family
thank you for the question
representative long yes that's what um
what our intent was when we suggested
and i'm sorry i don't have a copy of the
amendment so i don't know the exact
language but um but the person who's
taking care of the child and that may be
a foster parent or it may be you know
upon return to a biological parent
just so that we're that whoever is with
the child knows what medications the
child is on knows what the side effects
are to watch for it knows what the um
what the intended therapeutic effect are
so that we know you know whether it's
safe and also effective
like essentially how a parent would
monitor you know their own child's care
uh can i follow up madam chair
follow
so the the language says uh shall
include consultation with child
caregiver or lady legal guardian
um
and the dcyf district nurse so i
so
i'm thinking that the child caregiver
is the foster parent i i
i'm looking to include the foster parent
yeah so i don't want the foster parent
to be excluded if there's a legal
guardian or the nurse
suffices but what you're saying is that
that language would include the foster
parent correct
thank you for the clarification
representative long i i think that's the
intention
um i think what i
i
i we we certainly wanted to include the
foster so the caregivers anyone who's
taking care of the of the child which
could be phosphate maybe that's a need
for a definition there um but also
listening to you read it out i i do get
worried about logistics and wonder if we
shouldn't um have the language say and
or
um or when it possible because that
because we're talking now about three
people the district nurse the caregiver
um and the potentially the guardian and
if and we don't want to delay care
because we can't get all three people
into a room but they but a consultation
with them could also just be a phone
call and a conversation and follow up
okay and another uh one more follow-up
if i may another question
one more follow-up
okay uh you you mentioned dcyf oversight
when
reviewing the bill
i don't see specific dcyf oversight i
see department of health and human
service
monitoring but it's not specific to
dcyf
we assume that
health and human services would
be
the division of dcyf
thank you for that question i um i'm i'm
i guess i would assume that and and i'm
sorry i didn't see that language
but if the if the dcyf nurse is there
and monitoring then that is dcyf
oversight i would assume
okay great thank you
and i i guess i would add in some cases
um there may be uh
um
employees from children's behavioral
health
bureau
um who are not dcyf's but but i believe
that the nurses are dcyf employees
thank you we will you take one more
question
i'm happy to thank you
thank you representative all chiller you
have a question
um uh thank you madam chair uh thank you
uh dr o'neill for being here and
actually uh representative long asked
all my questions so
okay well i'm glad your questions were
answered
uh do we have any further questions
thank you dr o'neal for your testimony
thank you very much for the opportunity
and didn't you did you say that you
submitted written i i did thank you i i
forwarded it last night
if you don't have it i'm happy to send
resent copies no i thought i saw it so
thank you very much thank you
next we have
next we have patrick ho
um
you can unmute yourself sir
hello can you all hear me
yes
great thank you good morning madam chair
chairman and members of the committee
for the record my name is dr patrick hoe
and i'm the president of the new
hampshire psychiatric society my
testimony represents that of the new
hampshire psychiatric society as well as
the new hampshire medical society of
which i am an executive council member
i wanted to keep my testimony short
today to exceed most of my time to
uh tamora o'neil but i also wanted to
thank dr marsh for his leadership on
this issue and his enthusiasm in working
with us at the new hampshire psychiatric
society as well as the office of the
child advocate
we believe as does dr marsh that it is
important to ensure that children in
foster care are able to access
evidence-based treatment for general
health and mental health disorders as it
pertains to psychotropic medications it
is important to note that in many cases
as as mora had said these medications
are appropriate for mental health
disorders in children however we as a
state have a shortage of psychiatrists
and an even more pronounced shortage of
psychiatrists with specific child and
adolescent training so our work with dr
marsh ensures that this bill will
protect the welfare of our state's
children in foster care while not
impeding the ability of physicians to
treat children in foster care with
evidence-based measures
so with that i will leave that there and
once again look forward to supporting
this bill
alongside dr marsh and the office of the
child advocate thank you for your time
and i welcome your questions
thank you dr ho do you uh have written
testimony that you could submit to the
committee
um i do not but i can sure uh submit
what um the the sentiments that i had
spoken
to today
and i will do that after
after any questions
thank you kindly do i have any questions
for dr ho
seeing none thank you for your time
next we have rebecca ross welcome you
can unmute yourself
good morning madam chair members of the
committee thank you for the opportunity
to testify my name is rebecca ross i am
general counsel and legislative liaison
for the division for children youth and
families um i do apologize i have not
had the benefit of seeing the amendment
um so my testimony is based on as
introduced we're happy to work with the
folks that have drafted potential
amendments um and would welcome them
reaching out and working with them on
those amendments so that we can help
build a better system for kids in foster
care
to clarify a couple of the prior points
and questions that have already been
raised
um with regard to representative long's
question about dcyf oversight the way
that this would
um
be focused on dc white f having control
of the oversight is the statutes that
are invoked 169 b c and d as well as 170
g those are
child protection children in native
services and delinquency as well as dcyf
services
so
by way of including those in
this bill it directly connects to dcyf
having the responsibilities over these
functions
additionally i wanted to
provide
a little more information about the
doctor at sysc who is available to all
of dcyf for consultation it is included
in his contract that he will be
available for that work and to work with
both the dcyf nurses as well as
providers to children in the community
that was intentionally added into his
contract when it was drafted it was it
is not just available because of the low
census at sysc that was an intentional
ask and requirement as we sought to have
that doctor engaged for this express
purpose
taking a step back
i want to the committee to understand
that the department absolutely
recognizes that our responsibility for
the monitoring of psychotropic meds for
children in foster care is an absolute
priority
however decisions should be based made
based on current and accurate
information
and the oig report uses data that was
nearly five years ago so although we're
talking about the numbers that were in
that as the driving force for that bill
it's not reflective of where we are
today
um one of the reasons new hampshire's
numbers are
high are because we include the chin's
population and the delinquency
population
in our foster care data most other
states do not
while even removing that population we
recognize we want to do better for the
children and youth in our care and are
addressing the issue but one of the
driving forces under those numbers is
the way our data is collected and our
inclusion of the entire population
in the foster care system
uh
so we have taken a number of steps that
have already been discussed by moira and
other folks who have testified including
um
the ability to add nurses back in
through the budget we have nurses added
to almost all of the district offices
there are a couple more to fill as you
i'm sure can appreciate during covent
has been a difficult time to hire nurses
but we
um are almost there and those nurses one
of their responsibilities under their
new job descriptions is in fact to
monitor psychotropic meds for children
in foster care and consult with the
doctor at sysc regarding
those youth so we believe that is in
place it is building it is growing and
as
those nurse positions are all filled we
will do even better with that um the
mcos are also working on this we've
built things into their contracts to
monitor the use of psychotropic
medication for all foster youth um as
one of the elements that we monitor
through the mcos and we score them and
we have compliance measures that have
been built into the new contract so we
believe that will help improve
um this issue as well we have some
additional work to do with the
collaboration between the mcos and the
division and that is underway um i
wanted to point out as moira did as well
that the definition was not consistent
with 126u we believe 126u does
prevent that misuse of psychotropic
medications as a restraint it already
does in the law therefore adding this
into 169bc is duplicative um but if it's
going to be in both places we would
certainly like the definitions to be
consistent for implementation purposes
otherwise we're just creating
inconsistencies and confusion
um
so we believe we've taken a number of
steps to do this
um that this legislation
although well intended it is not
required because those places are those
pieces are already being built and put
in place
um with regard to the administrative
reporting while it is set up to go to
hhs we do
question would like you to consider
whether that would be more appropriately
directed to the children's oversight
committee um that deals with a lot of
the other
issues for this population
and
[Music]
there are a number of items in the
reporting that are not currently
reported through the medicaid system
or reported in the way that they are
described in the medicaid system or our
um
child welfare information system and
we believe it would be a substantial
work to get them connected in the way
that they are drafted so we would like
the opportunity to work with folks to
decrease the further burden of
additional reporting by working with
data in a way that we have it and can
combine it in a way that gets you the
information that you need but does not
require manual data tracking that is
very time intensive and um
just
unnecessary if we have other ways to
meet the needs of the committee and i'm
happy to do questions at any time
thank you
mr ross
representative long you have a question
thank you madam chair thank you thank
you miss ross so i just want to be well
first of all i uh commend the state of
new hampshire for including everybody
that's fantastic
uh so
so what i'm hearing is you're looking
for consistency in restraints
uh language and also
uh with reporting correct
yes that's right just looking at the
reporting requirements to make sure
they're feasible um within our current
systems that they don't have an
unintended cost and burden and that
as moira had suggested having the
definition match the one that already
exists in law
okay and just to follow up if i may uh
madam chair
certainly follow-up
yeah the the with respect to with
respect to both of those uh
language
um can the committee um
depend on you and the other parties
involved to
submit consistent language
yes absolutely
okay that'd be great thank you
thank you representative long we have
another question from
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking my
question
um in your testimony you said that this
is
duplicitive
or duplic
duplicative there we go um um
because we have a statute forbidding um
the use of psychotropic medications on
as a restraint is
so
this is um
seems to be more broad use of
psychotropic medications so
are you saying that psychotropic
medications are only used for restraint
no
this is not necessary as the as the oca
explained there are certainly
appropriate times when they are
medically necessary this bill is looking
at preventing the use of them for
improper restraint and when they're not
medically
necessary
and
um
that's already contemplated in
rsa126u that prevents the use of
improper use of medication restraints
and this bill incorporates 126u in each
of the sections saying they shall not be
used in violation of 126u which is where
it's already addressed
thank you
thank you um
representative belanger do we have any
more hands up
we do representative lewicki you have a
question
yes yes thank you madam chair and thank
you ms ross um i'm
somewhat uh unfamiliar with this and i
this is a general question approximately
how many children do we have in dcyf
care and what the breakdown is to in
foster care in
our other places
and how many of them are being treated
with psychotropic drugs
so i think i can get you that
information to follow up i don't have it
in front of me and don't want to um go
from my memory because that would be
dangerous right now so
i will get you that information we do
publish the annual report that has the
information about number of children in
care as well as our monthly dashboard i
will provide the committee with both of
those links and highlight that exact
information
and try to collect from medicaid
that
specific information on psychotropic
meds and get it to the committee thank
you um
do you have a follow-up
okay no
any further questions for rebecca ross
seeing none thank you rebecca you're
testing you're great
um and with that
seeing no further questions oh
we have another
person to testify it would be uh michael
skibby
mr skibby you can unmute
good morning madam chair and members of
the
committee my name is mike skibby i'm the
policy director at the disability rights
center
i just want to touch on a couple of
things
um
i won't
go over the ground that's already been
discussed um
first of all
i want to thank representative martian
the co-sponsors of the bill i think this
is very important
legislation to address
what i think everyone would agree is a
significant issue particularly in light
of the report from a few years back
[Music]
we support this bill i have not seen the
amendment nor the the
particulars of
recommended changes to the bill that
were discussed by
director o'neal
i did want to comment though on just a
couple of things just generally
um you may know this but i think some
people don't that there's an extremely
high rate of disability in the child
protection system
um and there's a lot of um
you know scholarship on
about why that is i think it's generally
understood that
the dynamic
um basically runs in both directions the
the existence of a disability may create
vulnerability
to abuse or trigger abuse or neglect
um and the
the imposition of maltreatment on a
child
um can cause disability itself
so you know it probably make would make
sense to you that a child with
disability can create stress in the
family
a child with disability may be less able
to
apprehend that
they are being abused or neglected or
otherwise defend
themselves and i think it should be
clear to everyone that being subjected
to abuse or neglect or other trauma can
cause disability particularly
behavioral health disorders so i think
it's important
especially important
that we ensure that children in the
system receive appropriate behavioral
health care and that includes proper
diagnosis and monitoring of treatment i
think that should be obvious i think
that the diagnosis issue though is worth
pausing
for a moment about
i think that it's in the nature of
children's behavioral health conditions
that
proper diagnosis depends on
you know careful
collection of information from the
child's caregiver
and so many of these children will have
come from homes where there was not a
reliable caregiver who can describe the
child's struggles with a treatment
provider
so
diagnosis is particularly challenging
and the need for careful monitoring of
treatment may therefore be especially
great because that diagnosis may not uh
rest on as solid ground as
uh as in other situations involving
children
it may also be particularly important
for the health care provider to work
closely with the foster family or other
caregiver so that their actions align
with and support the treatment plan
which we can expect to be more
challenging in the foster family setting
than in the context of an ongoing
uninterrupted parental relationship
um
so
those were a couple of things i
just wanted to
emphasize
um
i i have not seen the amendments but i
my ears perked up when i heard the
discussion of possibly
um changing the definition of medication
restraint and if i misheard i apologize
but i'm concerned that
the that the committee be cautious about
amending the definition of medication
restraint
in chapter 126 you itself
and i have a bit of post-traumatic
stress disorder about the history of
that statute because its original
version
basically had some definitions that
incorporated
language that made it very easy for the
regulated entities to avoid regulation
and so if you were considering
changing the definition of medication
restraint to
include what the purpose of the
medication was
i think you need to be very very careful
about that and so if that's being
contemplated i hope that there will be
an open discussion about
making sure that we protect the
the important uh
elements of chapter 126u
um with that i'd be happy to answer any
questions
thank you mr skibby representative long
you have a question
thank you madam chair thank you mr
skibby um so
with respect to the um uh
with respect to the um
assessments there's there's a
there's a recent comprehensive it needs
a recent comprehensive medical
assessment to rule out an underlying
physical cause
and a comprehensive
psychosocial assessment to address
psychosocial issues
um
so
so that's that's that's the um
you know that that's what
is needed prior to the
uh prescription
um so
a recent comprehensive medical
assessment could can you tell me what
what what's that time is that six eight
months two months three months
recent
uh well i i that's sort of the standard
of care in the health care setting that
i really
would not be able to speak to with any
expertise i would comment though that
ruling out
physical causes for behavior
behavioral symptoms
is an extremely important
thing to do particularly when you're
dealing with children i have a very
close relative who was treated for years
for
behavioral health issues that turned out
to have been related to an untreated
infectious disease and i've spoken to
healthcare providers in the behavioral
health field who
about this case and
have heard that reinforced many times
that it is very
common or at least you know it's a
frequent occurrence i should say to find
that there's a very close relationship
between
medical conditions and behavioral issues
that might otherwise not be understood
to be related to them
okay to follow if i may uh madam
follow up certainly thanks thank you uh
the um the use of medication restraints
shall be limited as provided in rsa 126u
uh which is in both the
has introduced bill in the um
proposed amendment um and miss ross and
miss o'neill will be
looking for consistent language if you
want to connect with them so thank you
madam chair thank you i will do that
thank you i see no further hands up
uh and i see no further
oh we do
a hand just came up uh cheryl avery you
wish to speak on this bill
i do thank you um honorable chair and
members of the committee i appreciate
your time on this matter today and the
opportunity to testify my name is cheryl
avery and i'm the policy coordinator for
children's behavioral health at new
futures
and i appreciate this opportunity and i
have submitted written testimony so i
will keep this brief
i'm here today in strong support of
house bill 120
along with representative marsha's
proposed amendment of today
this important legislation can go a long
way in the effort to reduce the use of
psychotropic medications and improve
outcomes for children in new hampshire's
care
certainly similar legislation in other
states has shown a dramatic decrease in
the use of psychotropic medications
i also want to thank representative
marsh for bringing this forward
prior to my policy work at new futures i
spent years working with children in new
hampshire both as a guardian ad litem
and within the residential placement
system and the issue of over-medication
has always been a matter of serious
concern
the ig's report that was cited by
representative marsh has shown a light
on this issue and i'm hopeful that we'll
use it to improve the care and treatment
of our state's most vulnerable children
by tightening oversight and ensuring
that every child who is prescribed
medication has a proper diagnosis and a
corresponding treatment plan we can be
more confident that every child
in the state's care is retreat receiving
the proper care and reach and treatment
i want to thank you for your
consideration of this important matter
and i hope that and i ask you to vote
ought to pass hb 120 with proposed
amendment
thank you
thank you ms avery any questions
unless one pops up i see no further
hands up for anyone who wants to testify
um
nope nothing
so i will read what i have for
statistics please correct me if i'm
wrong
we have
uh had six people testify
zero opposition and 74 in support
in barring any corrections with that i
will close
the hearing on house bill 120.
i will also let you know that our next
hearing is at one o'clock
so you're welcome to all go and have
some relaxing time
and lunch
and um
[Music]
representative long sure
yeah so with respect to amendments um
a commit committee has to introduce
the amendment during our exact session
correct
that is correct
but it doesn't it doesn't have to be our
amendment it could be like
representative marsha's amendment
correct
that is correct if there is an amendment
that is sent to the committee um we
somebody will introduce the amendment
during the exact session
and we will make motions on
that
amendment
and
discuss it at that time okay so with
respect to
120 uh
it looks like there's going to be
additions to this proposed amendment so
if they send it to the committee
um then we could introduce it if there's
an if there's
a different amendment
one of the members of the committee is
welcome to introduce it yes
okay great thank you
you're very welcome
any further discussion
well with that have a lovely lunch we'll
see you at one o'clock
welcome back everyone that is back
i hope you had a good relaxing lunch
time
representative
alessia madam clerk
are you ready to call the role
you need to unmute
i apologize
don't apologize we just want to hear
that lovely voice
representative alt schiller
do you want to give it a few minutes i
think maybe some of them aren't back yet
okay sure
okay we'll give it to
uh 105.
okay thank you
okay
you
um
okay everybody who's back according to
my uh laptop clock it is 105.
i will again ask their clerk to call her
up
good afternoon children and family law
committee
representative alt schiller
please state your name and who's with
you and where you are
i'm here i'm deborah altschuler i'm
still in stratham in my home office
thank you
representative belanger
uh thank you madam clerk i am in the lob
with representative wiki and chairman
chairwoman excuse me smell
thank you
representative cross
madam vice chair representative desimone
thank you madam clerk i am here in the
lob with representative blander and
lucky
thank you
representative grossman
hi everyone i am in my house in exeter
and i have one
child with me
in the house
hi i'm here i am still in the spare room
hello
thank you
representative lewicki
i am here in the lob with uh
representative bolanger and
representative desimone
thank you
representative litchfield
and here in my home in brentwood um i do
have two children and my husband here in
the home as well
thank you
representative long
i'm in my house alone
thank you
representative betrayed mill
i'm here in my home office alone
thank you
madam vice chair will someone be
replacing chair rice
this afternoon no madam clerk
okay thank you
representative denise smith
representative
wazir
yes i am home with uh four of the kiddos
though
thank you
representative kela
yes i'm home alone still thank you
thank you
madam vice chair so we have 15 members
and two are not with us
thank you madam clerk um
mr greenland i guess the youtube is a
streaming service
is all fixed never mind thank you
um i just wanted to be sure that people
can see what they should see
so with that we will open a hearing on
house bill 293
relative to the procedure for adoption
of a minor child
and i will recognize representative
belanger from rockingham 9
could you please state who you are
and
open your bill
thank you madam chair for the record my
name is representative cody belanger i
represent the town of epping new
hampshire
also considered the center of the
universe
today i present my bill house bill 293
relative to the procedure for the
adoption of a minor
um
there's also an amendment uh and that
would be
zero five nine zero h
which addre which i will address after
this but it addresses some other
um
word changes that i thought would be
necessary
for this bill to be
effective
while parents of these kids
roam free and do as they please
i mean by those these kids i mean kids
that are in the adoptive stage
filing petition after they are able to
file petition after petition
to get their children back
many adopted parents who also may be
their guardians whether related or not
are stressed
we need to get we need to be able to put
the power back into these people
most importantly these children
studies have proven that kids need
stability permanency is important
these families also need stability and
permanency
it does no one any good when they feel
like they are floating out in space not
knowing what the next steps are going to
be
the importance of stability and
permanency is always for the best
interest of the child let me give you a
few examples
my nephew
who i and my wife have guardianship of
and are in the process of the adoption
list
are trying uh he has picked his own name
so he now prefers to be called teddy
i say prefer because we haven't been
able to legally change his name yet
but my soon-to-be child comes out of his
room during the middle of the night
or when we're cooking dinner crying
beyond belief
because he's worried
that mommy's gonna take him away
i can't tell you the pain that it causes
me seeing how scared he is
and when he tells me hurry up i want you
guys to adopt me or why am i not adopted
yet i unfortunately have no answers
we are moving as fast as we can
and for the record my wife and i are in
the assessment process and are awaiting
the social worker to be assigned to our
home study
so this bill will not apply to us but
i'm putting this bill forward for the
many families that are struggling just
like we were
we have an opportunity to streamline the
process for these families
there may be a statement made today that
some would like to see an assessment
done either on the front end or the back
end but need need i let the committee
know that there isn't that isn't there
anyways
that part should be addressed in a
separate bill regarding when guardians
first apply for guardianship in the
first place
before you see an amendment
first line on line five
that is struck out is for good cause
shown
the reason why i strike that out
or the reason why is struck out in this
bill
is because if you are if
in lines a and b which are renumbered to
one and two and i'll get to that in a
minute
these are already the causes shown that
an assessment may be waived
so there is no further good cause shown
required
the next
uh
change is on line six you strike out
both
to either instead
so
the reason why i did that
is because
lines one and excuse me paragraphs one
and two will blend into one and will
read the parents of the minor child have
surrendered their rights the parents of
the minor child are deceased or the
parents parental rights have been
terminated
and the minor child has resided with the
petitioners
which strikes out to whom the child is
related that was on the original bill
for at least strikeout three two
consecutive years
prior to filing the petition for
adoption that now would become one
paragraph
and part b
which says or an assessment has
completed in the previous three years
the reason why i chose two consecutive
years
was excuse me let me back up the reason
why i chose to add the parents of the
minor are deceased or their parents
parental rights have been terminated
because not all situations
the parent will surrender their parental
rights sometimes you have to file for
determination in order for their rights
to obviously be terminated
sometimes the parents child are deceased
so
in order to make it more broad to apply
to different situations because not
every situation is the same i chose to
add that wording
when you move down to line 11 for at
least three to two consecutive years
it was brought to my attention that what
about the kids who are in a home for one
year
uh three months uh 12 days
and they get replaced with mom and dad
and then
go back to potentially the
petitioning adopted parents
that may or may not always be the case
and i would ask
i would refer that question to
miss ross who is on
um
how often
that would happen but this would mainly
apply to
um
adopt private adoptions and she will
address that as well
and then the reason why i added line 12
that an assessment has been completed in
the previous three years
is again
some of these parents
or soon to be adoptive parents whether
they're a relative or not
may feel
that they have no idea
the undertaking they are bringing into
their home
and the care and quality of life that
these children need so they may take for
example a foster parent class to better
understand
at risk youth
so
during that foster
if they choose to become foster parent
licensed
there is an assessment there
it is a very different assessment but it
is not that different
what an assessment consists of
is a background check
sex offender
check your previous 10 years of
employment
tax returns
five references one of them being
apparent
excuse me one of them being a family
member and the other four being
friends
and so so much more
this bill's main intent
is to reduce the number of years
required
from three
to
two in the previous years
we have made changes to
[Music]
parental rights and how they may be
terminated
i feel like this helps streamline this
process
and i ask the committee when it comes
forward
please pass this bill with the amendment
and i will be more than happy to take
questions
thank you representative
i see that representative long has a
question
uh yeah thank you madam chair and uh
thank you uh representative belanger and
also thank you for the love you're
showing to your nephew i believe you
said and for you and your wife showing
that love that that's fantastic he's a
lucky child
um
so
do we have a copy of the amendment
it was sent to you in an email
it was
okay
um
okay what's said by whom the
staff
me sir oh from you
it was sent yesterday afternoon around 1
30.
okay
when i received it from oauth
um
so the um
so an assessment i
i heard you say that an assessment that
there was two you referenced
um so it would be any assessment like an
iep or
whatever i mean it says an assessment so
i i i don't know if there are other
qualifications of assessments that the
court could deem
is qualifying
uh to if if i can answer your question
uh representative long thank you um and
thank you for your comments i very much
appreciate that sir um no
uh if you read further to bill
the bill excuse me excuse me if you
further the rsa
there are certain outlines that is
required
and considered an assessment so if i
give my child an iep assessment that's
not considered a statutory assessment
for a quote home study unquote
it has to be this is part
you could put the term home study in the
assessment and it i believe it is uh
quoted in the rsa but when you talk
about an assessment in this bill which
is statutory statutorily explained
throughout the rsa which is 170
um
it is very specific as to the
requirements um needed in an assessment
quote home study unquote
okay thanking a follower from a madam
chair
follow up sure uh and then in that
in that an assessment would also include
uh
your licensing qualifications
is that is that what i heard
is that what i heard
it's not me calling um
so
if you
yeah let me try to explain so
if you were a licensed foster parent
given a license
provided to you by dcyf
you are there is an assessment that goes
with that that's addressed in line b
or actually uh
another thought come to mind
if say i've had the child in my home for
two years we are petitioning for
adoption we are we've had the home study
done but for whatever reason a child may
be replaced with the parents
and then that doesn't work out um
the assessment would apply for that as
well
but
private guardians do not by
by petition to the court for
guardianship
do not
have
foster parent licenses and an assessment
doesn't give that license to private
guardians
i think i answered your question
yeah no you did yep um
and just follow up i may uh madam chair
yeah just um
i uh
the striking of uh to whom the child is
related i
i think i understand that has to why
should it just be related children
is that
is that the reason for striking that out
so
in my case the child is related to me
but again this bill even if it passed
tomorrow would not apply as i'm
currently in the process
nor would i accept
this
um as i consider it a conflict of
interest to
but anyway to whom the child is related
on line 10
striking that out
let me give you an example
prior to my nephew coming to live with
us
he lived with my
what we consider his pseudo grandparents
he lived with them for about two and a
half years this was in vermont and
unfortunately vermont's laws are not new
hampshire well maybe not unfortunately
but vermont's laws are very different
from new hampshire law
and
she couldn't do anything to obtain
custody of my nephew but had they lived
in new hampshire and this bill would
have
been enacted
if they wanted to be the petitioning
adoptees this bill would be able to
apply to them
not every situation the child is living
with a relative but that may be the best
place for the child to be
uh and i do want to drop one more
comment uh mr long and i and i
appreciate the questions um but uh one
thing to add is in all guardianship
cases when or excuse me in all adoption
cases a gal is appointed by the court
and as i eluded yesterday i was able to
petition for my own so that gil still
requires
excuse me is still required to draft a
court summary as to what is in the best
interest of the child so that is still
there as well
very good thank you
thank you representative wrong
next gabby grossman has a question go
ahead gabby
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative belanger for bringing
this forward
we've been involved
with adoption cases with families and
our house has been used as a visitation
site
so this is near and dear to me
my only concern so
private guardians
ensuring that there is a home study at
some point so children
cannot necessarily judge
making sure that someone is looking at
the home
when you listed the licensed foster
parent is that is there's a home study
in that but private guardians is there a
home study
no
um so
and again as i stated in my statement
i do intend to
draft a separate bill next session that
would address that
but that won't apply here
when
i'll use myself as an example
when i filed for guardianship of my
nephew
i thought that i would get some sort of
background check
i didn't
um
i do plan to address that but
the intent behind this bill is just to
reduce a number from three to two
um i do think that there should be at
minimum
when applying for guardianship
as this person would be taking on a
child that a background check and other
checks should be made such as no abuse
and neglect charges have been brought or
potentially put on that person as well
as potentially a sex offender check
as well
but again that that needs to be
addressed on the guardianship side which
is a separate
issue
um that would need to be brought forward
madam chair can i ask a follow-up
sure follow-up thank you
so in the process
is
whether it's three years or two years is
there a home study
does anyone go visit the home
that the child like in your case
in the process has anyone come
is it part of the process that somebody
goes into the physical home so not just
um
record
i'm sorry i'm losing my thought i just i
think i got what you were trying to say
physically going
to to ensure
that the home is a safe place because
the child
may think it's a safe but it may not be
and the child at that time may not have
the judgment but who is insuring from
the state
that we're placing these children
in safe homes
being that a home study
home assassin shall not be required
so
in a
guardianship case when dcyf is not
involved
short answer
no one
long answer
is
if in
if that person who is fight now remember
this only applies to the petitioning
adoptive parents
if my nephew didn't live with me and i'm
not
applying for a petition this would not
apply and i could not have it assessed
or waived excuse me
so
um geez i just lost my train of thought
i'm sorry um i
i believe you said it if in
if in so anything under currently where
the way that the law is right now three
years
um there has been nobody that has come
to my home so my wife and i will have
custody of my nephew three years this
august
in since obtaining custody in august of
2018 we have never seen an individual
visit our home to check to see if it's
safe
now while i do own a very safe home
and again should be addressed in another
separate rsa
and i will get there
um but yes in three years that we will
have him this august not a single person
has come to assess our home and again
just reiterating this and beating this
home this only applies to an assessment
if the petitioning if the petitioning
adoptees are the ones petitioning for
adoption
one more follow-up
and this may be too personal to answer
but i'm trying to get the landscape in
your case
is there dcyf involvement or is this a
private
we need to stay on the subject of the
bill
i mean i'll answer the question madam
chair if that's okay it's really quick
that's fine you're just not
required to
no
this is a private adoption case that i
filed with the court um
as a pro state litigate litigant at
first
thank you just trying to get the
landscape thank you
thank you
next questions coming from
representative altrula
thank you madam chair and thank you
representative belanger for taking my
question
um
just so we're all we're all clear and
i'm looking
at both your amendment
um 0590
and i'm looking at section 170b
and
under section 18
it says that the courts
have discretion
to order an assessment at any time
is that your understanding and is that
is that part of your thought process
yes amendment together
yes so that's not changing
okay
um may i follow up madam chair
yes you can have a follow up so i'm this
would add this would change
paragraph
and modify a and b
and it's and
it's my understanding and
please
correct me if i if i'm not understanding
this correctly representative belanger
in section six directly after five
section
6 says
notwithstanding
any of the above requirements the court
shall require a background check in all
private adoption proceedings if there
has not been an assessment so
with your
amendment
there's an either or
as discretion to order that background
check
yeah so a background check is not the
same thing as an assessment um the
background check is just getting your
fingerprints done at the uh
the the your local police department so
i did not want to touch that because i
felt like that was important
i'm sorry one of the just just to
clarify madam cheer um i'm sorry i
should have clarified representative
belanger
within the statute itself for those who
are not looking at it i think it says
the background check shall include a
criminal records check and a search of
the abuse and neglect registry
maintained by the department
and so
all of that actually none of that is
changed
with your amendment to section
five
correct it does not supersede section
six
correct you won't negate that
right thank you thank you for the
clarification
thank you for the question
thank you representative all chiller the
next
question comes from
representative joe keller
thank you and thank you for taking the
question
is
it not the case that if um there is a
private adoption then the
that is assuming that the um
the parental rights have not been
terminated and therefore
um
that
the responsibility of making sure that
the person
now
uh being set up to adopt is
um the responsibility of the current
guardian
and not the state
i don't understand the question
so
it's in reference to representative
grossman's
um question and your answer that no one
is suppose is checking to whether or not
um
in the situation of a private adoption
that the home is safe
and isn't that responsibility on the
current
um
in the in the
instance of a private adoption isn't
that responsibility on the
current persons uh
the current person that is
having a guardianship or
before the adoption
or you know control of the
of the
child in that case before the adoption
occurs
if i think i understand your question
representative thank you um if what
you're if i believe what you're saying
is that is the responsibility of the
adoptive parent to provide a safe and
stay uh safe home for a child
no no
yes i mean obviously that that is the
case but i'm talking about
who is responsible for making sure that
the um the new adoptive parents are
um providing that safe location is that
the current guardian and because the um
because the state has not taken control
of that uh guardianship right
that would be the guardian at lightham
so in any private
so
i i think i may have misspoke in the
going on three years that we have had
custody of my nephew there has been no
one as guardians come to our home in
check however a guardian at lightham
could technically visit the home
and provide
not an assessment that's probably not
the right term to use there but provide
and
look out if you will
of the conditions in which the home they
are living in
okay thank you and in that she would
provide that copy to the report to the
court okay thanks
do you have a follow-up representative
yo keller
no i think i've i've got enough thank
you
thank you
um
i see no further questions
and i see no further hands up
so with that no we get hands we do oh
boy these people are quick so they both
jumped at first who would you like
john dejoy
you're welcome to begin speaking
thank you madam chair
and i apologize for seeming so eager to
raise my hand um
for the record my name is john dejoy
representing waypoint
and i want to thank the bill's sponsor
for the work he's done in this
legislation and the way he's reached out
to folks who've had questions and tried
to remedy the concerns he's done a
significant amount of work on this and i
don't want my comments to reflect
anything other than respect for his work
um
one when we reached out internally in
waypoint to the
um
to the clinicians who run our foster
adoption program when this bill came
forward and talked to the bill about
them
talked about the bill with them
there was one issue that they raised
that i we are concerned
is not remedied by the proposed
amendment
and that is a situation
where a family member
will
self-place drop off if you will
whatever verb you'd like to use a child
with a family member
in those situations
if adoption is accomplished the way the
bill discusses
it is possible that that home would not
have any home study
either at the beginning or at the end
that's something that we that we think
is a concern
we think it's easily remedied
but wanted to raise it as a concern
and the suggestion would be in the
amended language
rather than the or
between b and c
if we replace the ore with an and
we believe that would remedy the um the
concern
and with that i i will conclude my
testimony
thank you mr dejoy um will you take
questions
of course
thank you representative all children
you are welcome to ask your question
thank you madam chair and thank you mr
joy for
entertaining my question so
in the event
um
of the the your hypothetical with uh
somebody self-placing you know choosing
a family member to
place their child with um
would it
would not
section uh 5a still apply that there
would have to be a termination
or a surrender of the parental rights
through the courts and would not not
trigger having a home assessment of
where that child was when someone
relinquishes their parental rights
representative thank you for the
question that's that's an excellent
question i don't want to portray myself
as an expert nor am i
i would prefer
not to guess at a response to that
question and i can tell you i do not
have a clear response to that question
thank you
representative long you have a question
thank you madam clark uh
mr joy where again you said between b
and c and
i'm seeing a and b wait where
would you replace the or with end
thank you for the question
representative and i'm i'm trying to as
we speak um
find the copy of the amendment that i
reviewed
i'm not able to put my hands on it that
quickly
um
uh okay representative that's that's
fine that's fine
line 11.
okay very good thank you
my apologies
and now i have the amendment in front of
me
thank you mr joy and representative any
further questions
um
representative lewicki okay thank you
madam chair thank you mr dejoy can you
give us any idea how much an assessment
costs is this something that is within
the reach of parents or is it a very
expensive process
i'm happy to get that information for
your representative and
and respond to the committee i do not
have that information
when i spoke to our
adoption department i didn't get into
that level of detail it was more you
know how how should we approach this
bill so it's much a much higher level
but i'm happy to talk to our adoption
department and get a response for you
thank you
thank you mr dejoy i see no further
questions
i see oh
i do see one representative
thank you uh
for recognizing me and thank you for
taking the question
um
kind of on the same topic that i just um
mentioned especially since you are uh
uh speaking to that isn't it uh so
you're saying that in
private adoption situations
um
that the current current guardian
essentially
places the child in what they believe to
be a suitable home and you're
statement
seems to be that the government needs to
go and double check that even though
their rights have not been terminated
yet is that is that your position
uh not exactly representative thank you
for the question um what i what i was
referring to is not private adoptions
what i was
referring to is unofficial placements
where a particular family member for
whatever personal reason
will decide they cannot properly care
for their child and will place that
child with another family member
we believe it it is
it is typically
preferable
for a family member to care for another
for a child of the family
our concern though comes in with these
unofficial placements
if it moves to
a permanent to an adoption
that the adoptive family
might not have any scrutiny
that's that's our concern
it's my understanding that private
adoptions have it have a formal process
that they follow as well
okay thank you
i'm going to give it 30 seconds to see
if anybody's quick and puts their hand
up i don't want to miss anybody's
question or testimony
gabby grossman
there you go go ahead
thank you madam chair and thank you mr
joy it's so good to hear you not see you
but good to hear you
thank you representative it's nice to be
here with the committee as well
um
so in those unofficial placements
where maybe um parental rights haven't
been surrendered
the unofficial placements is there dcyf
involvement
when there is when there is some formal
involvement we're less concerned
it's when there's no dcyf involvement
that we're that we're concerned
so the illustration that was given to me
is a family member has a particular
personal crisis
can't
cannot care for their child and decide
that aunt uncle grandmother brother
sister whomever
here i needed i need you to
take responsibility for my kid i can't
do it
and that parent at some point
just doesn't come back
for whatever reason
and the custodial
parent at that point moves for adoption
so
i'm not trying to purport that this is a
that this is a frequent occurrence what
i'm trying to suggest it that is that
this is a potential occurrence that
causes us concern
thank you
thank you another question from
representative yokela
thank you and thank you for taking the
question um so
currently
if
uh the private placement happens and um
the three years
um
the child is with them for three years
no assessment is required but you
you're trying to also chan change that
policy
in that
with this change right
because it's currently not required if
they're with them for three years
um but you're suggesting that it should
be changed to require that now
right
we
we believe that many families who foster
have an assessment of their home done
before they begin fostering
other families when they adopt
have a home assessment
what we're suggesting is that it ought
not to be both
but it should be at least one or the
other
thank you for your answer
thank you
any other questions from mr dejoy
thank you mr de joy for your testimony
and the answers to questions
thank you madam chair
thank you next we'll hear from rebecca
ross you can unmute yourself
good afternoon madam chair and members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to provide testimony for the
record my name is rebecca ross i'm
general counsel and legislative liaison
for the division for children youth and
families
the division takes no position on this
bill partly because we do not
believe that it would impact
dcyf related cases
um
we've heard a lot of
different
um discussion about various parts of the
system i'd like to provide some
clarification
as to the roles responsibilities and the
process and how this fits into that
um so you can understand why we do not
believe it applies to dcyf related cases
um in the first instance to clarify
guardianship when there is a private
guardianship um
dcyf is involved in that we receive a
request for a check of our central
registry directly from the court when
anyone files a petition for guardianship
of a minor under rsa
um they're required to give consent to
be checked on the adult registry that
goes through elderly and adult services
a criminal records check through state
police and a central registry check for
us we process um
i just checked the number and i
apologize i forget but hundreds and
hundreds of those a year for the courts
um and send them directly back to the
court so everyone who's appointed a
private guardian through the judicial
branch is checked on our central
registry if they are seeking to be the
guardian over a minor um and that is the
level of our involvement if it's a
private guardianship case
um in cases where dcyf is involved we
look at homes at a number of different
times and places throughout a case one
if someone is seeking foster care
licensure we do a look at the home for
the purpose of the license
if they become licensed at the time
they replace a child there are eyes on
that home as well
further if the case does move to
termination of parental rights and
reunification is not successful then we
do an adoption home study which is
looking at is this
home
the in the best interest of the child
for permanency and
to make it their permanent family so we
are looking at that home at a number of
different times with different lenses
throughout the life of a case
if we are not involved and it is
um
a private guardianship and a
private adoption
then our involvement
is by way of licensing child placing
agencies who are regulated under 170e
and under our administrative rules hec
which require the elements of that home
study and that that study is looking at
whether or not that's
for adoption purposes the the best
option for permanent theme adoption they
also do home studies for foster
placements
um under that child placing agency
license so it's very complicated but the
times and places that the division or
licensed child placing agency is
involved
but
we believe this does not touch on most
of those areas
and
the bill is tailored to the cases where
um it is in fact a private adoption dcyf
has not been involved it is not a
licensed foster home
um
the court
through the judicial branch has
vetted that home has agreed to placement
has required annual reports and reviews
to go back before the court
and then considers the adoption petition
under this statute um i'm happy to
answer any questions but i hope that
provides some clarity
thank you do we have any questions gabby
grossman you have a question
thank you for taking my question and um
so just to clarify in
the last sentence you just said in a
private adoption
the judicial branch
overseas that home study before before
agreeing to the adoption
yes the judicial branch is the one that
requires it and sees it um when a
petition is filed it is the law that
requires it to happen or
be waived under certain circumstances so
dcyf is not involved
other than being the entity that
regulates child placing agencies who may
be doing that assessment
thank you you're welcome
thank you representative all schiller
you have a question
thank you madam chair and uh thank you
miss ross for taking my question
my question is with reference you just
made a reference in your testimony to
the judicial
uh
to rules and the
statute that you follow and i'm looking
at 170
and it looks like in 170 c9 there is a
social study prior to disposition
is that what you're referring to that a
social study is made by the department
of health and human services or another
agency
so that is the social study that is done
under 170 c when we are petitioning for
termination of parental rights
additionally under 170 b if we were um
doing
the petition for adoption
following a termination of parental
rights we would an adoption home study
specific to that home
and the statutory requirements under
170b so we certainly do that that study
under 170c when we're trying to meet our
burden under termination and provide an
adoption study report at the time of the
adoption matter
and follow-up chair
yes representative thank you so just to
just to follow up on on uh on that
thread
as this bill is written and i'm just
dealing i'm i'm looking at the amendment
but also
in the original
um
it says the
if either of the following circumstances
are met the parents of the minor child
have surrendered their parental rights
minor child are deceased
or the parents parental rights have been
terminated so under surrender
and terminate
back up under deceased
would dcyf not be working with probate
and under the probate courts and under
surrender of rights and termination of
rights would not dcif be involved with
that child
not in all of the cases no for example
if the parents die and a grandparent
immediately goes and gets guardianship
through the judicial branch and there is
no report of abuse or neglect dcif would
not be involved so um i think it depends
on under both of those circumstances
sometimes we are sometimes we are not
thank you
welcome
thank you representative long did you
have a question
oh it's been addressed thank you madam
chair
thank you representative i was
seeing
new
further questions
um
thank you miss ross for your testimony
and we will now move on
we i show no further hands of people who
want to testify
so
with that i'll read the stats for
house bill 293
we have five people
or more in support
we had
um
we had three people testify
and with that i will close the hearing
on house bill 293
i'm going to give madam clerk a few
minutes to get herself together and then
we will open our
uh one o'clock which is
late by
uh 1 30 rather which is late by almost
30 minutes and i apologize
to uh represent
representative massimilia
um
but our questions and testimonies on
every bill are extremely important
just as it will be for yours so as soon
as the clerk is ready we will begin
i'm all set madam by share
thank you representative alessia i will
now open
bill
house bill
as introduced
exempting the victims of trafficking in
persons
from participating in children in need
of services proceedings representative
massimilia would you like to
open with your testimony
representative massimilia are you there
thank you madam chair can you hear me
yes we can thank you good afternoon
good afternoon madam chair and members
of the committee
um
i introduced house bill 562 and what i
would like to respectfully request
is that the committee retained the bill
um the reason why i'm asking for a
retention is simply because
last week
hhs got in touch with me we had a
conversation at the end of the week
with their concerns
and then
we were going to amend the bill
but
i was contacted by other people with
other concerns and so we mutually agreed
that if we could have time to work on
the bill collectively
that it would improve it and make it
better and therefore we're asking for a
return to the bill to be retained
thank you representative
any questions for the representative
um seeing none
i thank you so much uh for your request
and i thank you for your testimony
the next
next we will move on to keith keaning
you can unmute yourself
and we'd love to hear what you have to
say
i
guess mr keane doesn't want to speak
right now
so
excuse me
he just dropped maybe he'll come back
so right now we have uh rebecca ross
with her hand up she'd like to testify i
believe rebecca
you're on good afternoon again madam
chair and members of the committee thank
you for the opportunity to provide
testimony today we appreciate the
conversation and work we've had with
representative matamilla and agree that
retaining the bill for further work is
the appropriate
approach at this time briefly i'd like
to explain that
we had concerns that
removing the availability of the chins
program which we see as a service driven
program rather than a punitive program
would have an unintended consequence of
removing one of the doors to treatment
and services available to
um minor victims of trafficking we think
there are some other ways to approach
that besides closing the door completely
um and have agreed to work on that
language and approach going forward so
we
appreciate representative matthew
hearing us and look forward to working
with
the representative and other individuals
who had some concerns about this bill
and i'm happy to take any questions
thank you do we have any questions for
ms ross
seeing none
madam chair
representative i will say
i just need miss frost to share i
believe she's the liaison for
children and family if she could just
share again with her
yes
i am general counsel and legislative
liaison for the division for children
youth and families at dhhs
thank you you're welcome
one of these days i'll get it
representative
so i can make your job a little bit
easier
sometimes i can remember
i didn't remember
her full
title
okay so next we have uh joey smith
are you there
yes yes i am thank you
welcome
uh so good afternoon madam chair members
of the committee my name is joy smith
and i'm the program director at the new
hampshire coalition against domestic
violence we're the umbrella organization
for the 13 community-based crisis
centers in new hampshire
i'm also here representing the new
hampshire human trafficking
collaborative task force which is a
group of law enforcement
officers service providers attorneys
state agencies and community
stakeholders dedicated to improving the
statewide response to human trafficking
in granite state
i am here to speak in opposition of
house bill 562
a bill that would weaken the service
provision for victims of human
trafficking by exempting them for
participating in the new hampshire
children in need services or the chins
proceedings
i really appreciate everybody giving me
the opportunity to
share this testimony today and i am in
agreement with
what attorney rebecca ross from dcyf
shared earlier regarding chin services
in new hampshire and we're also
really grateful to representative
muscamilla's commitment to improving new
hampshire's response to human
trafficking and we really look forward
to collaborating with her on future
legislation we certainly appreciate her
willingness to work with us in finding
solutions to strengthen services for
human trafficking victims in the state
the coalition and human trafficking task
force are not aware of any problems with
our current chin's process here in new
hampshire and
we do have serious concerns with the
impact that this legislation would have
for child victims of human trafficking
in their families
chins proceeding in new hampshire are
not are
a non-punitive way to ensure that the
children get the services
they need after experiencing abuse and
victims of human trafficking are exposed
to significant amounts of trauma and it
is essential
that we are connecting them to the best
resources available to them as part of
their healing process
in my role as a program as the program
director and in previous capacities as a
confidential advocate i've seen
firsthand how effective these services
are for children and families um here in
the granite state children who
experience trauma such as trafficking
they require a holistic
support um and shins is able to provide
that with dedicated staff providing
individualized counseling guidance
supervision treatment and rehabilitation
um
so you know we certainly urge uh that
to
vote no on this on house bill 562 and
i appreciate everybody's time
and i'd be happy to answer any questions
that you might have
thank you do we have any questions
seeing none i'll thank you for your
testimony and
thank
the entire committee
for all of its work
uh in the last two days committee
members we have
gone through 12
very emotional bills
i thank you for all your hard work
putting up with me
um in my
infancy of sitting in as chair
and appreciate
your patience
please stay tuned to your calendar to
see when we'll meet next
so madam chair did you close the hearing
on 562.
i have closed i apologize thank you keep
me on my toes representative long
um i will close uh the hearing on um
on house bill
562.
um
where's my stats
my stats here
show
there are 38 in support
two in opposition
and we had uh four people testify
and with that we will close that hearing
and
we will be meeting next week
representative bolanger tells me
so
stay tuned for what time and place
and we'll see you then
thank you and drive safely
and stay safe
so
so we don't oh so it's your calendar
right that the day that we're meeting in
the calendar should be in the calendar
today
i believe it's the 11th uh but yes it'll
be in the calendar okay
oh yeah okay
okay you love it yeah okay thank you
you're welcome
thank you everyone
have a good day
thank you